[Music]
in this video we're going to walk
through how to peer your google cloud
vmware engine environment to your
project and to your virtual private
network hi my name is ron shitnani with
google cloud before we actually walk
through the steps to perform the actual
peering let's take a look at an overview
of the overall concept that we're trying
to achieve
on the left side you've got your
on-premises network connected to google
cloud via the partner interconnect or a
direct interconnect
then we have your google cloud platform
project your gcp project where you have
your virtual private network
and then on the far right we have google
cloud vmware engine where you may have
one or more private clouds deployed in
one or more regions what we'll be doing
here is building the connection between
your virtual private network in your gcp
project
and the google cloud vmware engine so
the links that you see on the right side
of the image between the vpc
and google cloud vmware engine now let's
get started with the actual peering
steps first thing we're going to do is
go to our google cloud project and go to
the main menu and visit the vpc network
screen
under vpc networks you may already have
vpcs created we'll select the one that
we want to peer with and so that gcp can
communicate with it
then we're going to select private
service connection
enable the api if you haven't done so
before or haven't leveraged private
service connection before
and we're going to reserve a slash 24
range by allocating an ip range
if you already have an ip reserved from
other psa
connectivity such as cloud sql you can
re-leverage the existing one
in our case we're going to reserve a
slash 24 and all this does is reserves
it so that no one can use it in that vpc
next we'll click on private connections
to services and create the actual
connection by selecting google cloud
platform and selecting the range that we
just created so let's go ahead and click
ok
and connect
now we're going to enable the ability to
export and import routes by default this
only exports routes so we're going to
click on vpc network peering select
service networking and hit edit and
import as well as export the routes and
hit save
now this is done our private service
connection is created we can go to the
vmware engine portal and establish the
peering in the reverse direction
we'll go ahead and click on network and
private connection
and in this view we're going to hit add
private connection select vpc network
from the services
as you can see we also have a netapp
cloud volume peering available
next we're going to select the region
where our gcp instance is deployed
and paste in details of the project we
want to peer with such as the project
name
project number
and the vpc id or the vpc name in this
case
this next section about the tenant
project id is something we will get from
the vpc details by going to vpc network
peering
and under the service networking section
you'll see a peer project id that we
will copy and this will end in the
letters dash tp
as in tenant project and then of course
we can leave the routing mode as global
or regional generally you want to have
it as global
and it'll show as connecting in the next
screen
after a few minutes have passed you'll
see this connecting stage change to
connected and now we can view the routes
that are exchanged between your private
cloud
and your vpc so as you can see here
we're importing a route from the vpc
and we are exporting all the gcv ranges
to it
same thing on your service networking
view back in your project
you can view what routes are being
imported into your vpc and what is being
exported into google cloud vmware engine
and as you can see these are all showing
as accepted by pier
under status now that we have the
ability to reach our vmware engine
components let's verify that we're able
to log into vcenter and other pieces of
the environment by spinning up a google
compute engine vm
and in this case i'm going to go ahead
and rdp to my existing virtual machine
that exists in compute engine
and once we're in the actual machine as
you can see that i'm able to launch a
browser and visit the vsphere login page
let's go ahead and test a few network
connectivity tests by pinging other
components within the vsphere management
range in order to verify connectivity
which as you can see is coming back as
well you can perform this vpc peering
step in order to reach other google
cloud vmware regions as well as connect
the existing region to multiple virtual
private networks
so in effect you have the ability to
peer against multiple virtual private
networks to learn more about google
cloud vmware engine visit our site at
cloud.google.com
vmware dash engine
[Music]
you